en el último vídeo aprendimos cómo
asignarle la configuración absoluta
rsa a los centros de calidad y en este
vídeo vamos a aplicar el mismo concepto
para compuestos cíclicos así que si
miramos este compuesto cíclico sabemos
que tenemos un carbono justo aquí
déjenme ponerlo con amarillo y este va a
ser mi centro de calidad muy bien
entonces no es difícil que ustedes lo
hagan por su cuenta pueden verlo por su
cuenta este va a ser mi centro de
calidad mi estéreo centro o mi centro
estéreo génico o como sea que quieran
llamarlo ok y este es un carbono con
hibridación sp3 y con cuatro distintos
grupos atados a él verdad así que
tenemos distintas trayectorias a lo
largo de este anillo así que si éste es
mi centro de quiralidad este de aquí hay
que ponerle su asterisco verdad la
pregunta es si es un centro de calidad r
o un centro de calidad ese y para
descubrir lo necesitamos dibujar esta
molécula de nuevo y mostrar algunos de
los enlaces
así que por ejemplo si tomamos nuestro
centro de calidad vamos a ponerlo
digamos aquí verdad este está unido
hacia la izquierda con un carbono que a
su vez tiene dos hidrógenos verdad
entonces tiene dos hidrógenos ahí lo
tienen y este a su vez también está
unido a un carbono este carbono de la
misma forma está unido a dos hidrógenos
y a
carbono verdad ahora si nos vamos hacia
la derecha de nuestro centro de calidad
este es nuestro centro de calidad
tendremos otro carbono que está
nuevamente unido a dos hidrógenos verdad
tenemos este carbono unido a dos
hidrógenos y que a su vez está unido a
otro carbono ahora bien ese carbono
corresponde a este de aquí y este está
unido a un hidrógeno por un lado a un
hidrógeno por un lado y está unido a un
carbono con un doble enlace entonces
vamos a
a pretender que está unido a dos
carbonos y esto es bastante útil cuando
estamos asignando la letra r o s verdad
vamos a pretender que de hecho está
unido a dos carbonos ok aunque realmente
esté unido al mismo carbono verdad ahora
si nos regresamos al centro de
quiralidad este está unido digamos con
esta con esta cuña verdad está unido a
un carbono que a su vez está unido a
tres hidrógenos tres hidrógenos y hacia
atrás de este carbono se encuentra
nuestro hidrógeno muy bien y ahora que
ya tenemos nuestros cuatro grupos vamos
a ver si podemos asignar las prioridades
así que lo primero que podemos ver es
que el átomo que está atado directamente
a mi centro de quiralidad es de hecho
este es de hidrógeno verdad que está
atado a mi centro de quiralidad tiene
tiene la prioridad más baja verdad
porque nosotros vamos a tener que
comparar hidrógeno con carbono carbono y
carbono que son los átomos que están
directamente unidos al centro de
quiralidad entonces la prioridad más
baja le corresponde a este hidrógeno y
los otros tienen un empate verdad
entonces vamos a ver cuál sería el que
sigue ahora comparamos estos tres este
carbono está perdón a un hijo a tres
hidrógenos eso quiere decir que podemos
poner hh h este carbono está unido a dos
hidrógenos y un carbono entonces podemos
poner c
h h verdad y finalmente este hoy carbono
de aquí está unido a dos hidrógenos y un
carbono entonces podemos ponerse h h muy
bien entonces cuando nosotros empezamos
a hacer la digamos el desempate tenemos
que comparar el primero verdad el
primero o el de él
podemos comparar estos tres primeros
verdad entonces tenemos aquí un
hidrógeno que compite con carbonos
entonces este de aquí será el de
prioridad más baja verdad entonces como
ya habíamos asignado un 4 aquí irá un 3
y si nos damos cuenta estos empatan
nuevamente verdad tenemos exactamente
los mismos átomos así que tenemos que
seguir sobre nuestra cadena si nosotros
seguimos ahora tenemos que este carbono
se encuentra unido a dos hidrógenos de
un carbono entonces podéis ver podríamos
poner esto así verdad y este carbono de
aquí está unido a dos carbonos y un
hidrógeno entonces tenemos
de esta forma verdad y ahora bien si
hacemos el desempate podríamos ver que
el primero coinciden sin embargo en el
segundo tenemos un hidrógeno y un
carbono el carbono tiene un número
atómico más grande por lo tanto este
lado va a tener un va a ser va a tener
una mayor prioridad que el lado
izquierdo entonces aquí vamos a tener
la prioridad el número uno digamos en
prioridad y este va a tener el número
dos a que corresponde eso en este
diagrama pues corresponde aquí el número
uno aquí el número dos el número tres
corresponde a este grupo metilo que está
saliendo hacia hervir hacia digamos
hacia nosotros y este hidrógeno tiene la
prioridad más baja verdad entonces como
ya está el hidrógeno digamos apuntando
hacia atrás de la hoja nosotros tenemos
que la orientación está dado justamente
de esta forma y por lo tanto le
corresponde la letra r verdad la letra r
porque esta orientación es en el sentido
de las manecillas del reloj
muy bien vamos a hacer otro ejemplo
vamos a ver este ejemplo de aquí ahí lo
tienen aquí nosotros tenemos una
molécula llamado esta molécula se llama
carbon a ok
esta es la carbono y la carbono tiene un
centro de calidad y que es este carbono
justo que tenemos aquí muy bien este es
nuestro centro de calidad perdón centro
de calidad y nuevamente va a ser muy
útil dibujar todos nuestros átomos así
que por ejemplo podríamos poner aquí
nuestro centro de quiralidad este es
nuestro carbono y este está unido
digamos hacia arriba con otro carbono
que a su vez está unido a dos hidrógenos
verdad aquí tenemos la unión con dos
hidrógenos y con un carbono más verdad
este carbono que corresponde al grupo
carbón y lo que tenemos aquí presente
ahora este carbono tiene un doble enlace
con un oxígeno entonces como como
hicimos en el ejemplo anterior vamos a
digamos a suponer que está unido a dos
oxígenos díaz
como ya vimos en el ejemplo anterior
para poder hacer el desempate a la hora
de asignar prioridades y luego bueno
este por supuesto está unido a otro
carbono qué pasa ahora si nos vamos a
digamos este este grupo de aquí que
tenemos la saliendo de la hoja de papel
entonces aquí tenemos esta cuña verdad
que está unido bueno esta cuña 12
carbonos verdad y este carbono está
unido por un lado a otro carbono y hacia
abajo está unido
otro carbono con un enlace doble
entonces vamos a suponer que está unido
a dos carbonos y voy a omitir ahorita
esos hidrógenos a los cuales están
unidos muy bien entonces ahí nos
quedamos y finalmente vamos a ver qué
pasa si nos vamos hacia abajo verdad o
hacia la derecha aquí tenemos este
carbono que está unido a dos hidrógenos
muy bien y este de aquí está unido a
otro carbono verdad que a su vez está
unido a un hidrógeno por un lado y unido
a otro carbono pero con un enlace doble
entonces vamos a poner que está unido a
dos carbonos muy bien
y ahora que ya hemos dibujado todo vamos
a ver si podemos descubrir cuáles son
los grupos o cuál es la prioridad de
estos grupos y también necesito por
cierto agregar mi hidrógeno que tenemos
aquí apuntando hacia asia hacia atrás de
la hoja verdad
y que de hecho se me estaba olvidando
porque tiene la prioridad más baja
verdad tiene la prioridad más baja y que
tiene el número 4 muy bien entonces
ahora vamos a comparar las las otras
los otros átomos verdad estos son átomos
de carbono todos tienen el mismo número
atómico claramente entonces tenemos que
hacer el desempate vamos a ver este
carbono está unido a un carbono y dos
hidrógenos entonces podemos poner un
h h verdad este carbono de aquí abajo
está unido a 3 carbonos tenemos csc y
este carbono de aquí está unido déjenme
los voy marcando está unido a un carbono
y dos hidrógenos entonces este de aquí
tiene un c h h como hacemos el desempate
pues nos fijamos en el primero y nos
fijamos que los tres coinciden en que
están unidos a un carbono sin embargo
este grupo de aquí verdad va a tener una
prioridad mucho más alta que estos dos
porque tiene unidos un carbono mientras
que estos dos tienen hidrógenos verdad
entonces este grupo de aquí se va a
llevar la prioridad más alta mientras
que estos dos nuevamente tienen un
empate así que tenemos que irnos con el
siguiente carbono este carbono de aquí
está unido a dos oxígeno si un carbono
entonces podríamos poner algo así
mientras que este carbono está unido a
dos carbonos y un hidrógeno entonces
ponemos ese h verdad entonces aquí viene
el desempate porque el número atómico
del oxígeno es mayor que el número
atómico del carbono entonces este grupo
o más bien digamos este lado de aquí
recibe la prioridad número 2 mientras
que este de abajo recibe la prioridad
número 3 ok
así que si lo ponemos en nuestro en este
en este diagrama verdad vamos a tener
que este tiene el número 1 éste tiene el
número 2 y este tiene el número 3 verdad
entonces podemos ver que esto tiene esta
orientación verdad aquí podemos asignar
esta orientación y entonces esta carbono
como estamos dando una orientación en el
sentido de las manecillas del reloj va a
tener una r es el ere carbono así que lo
que tenemos aquí es el enantiómero r de
la carbono y vamos a ver si podemos
dibujar la imagen espejo entonces
déjenme mover todo esto
a ver si podemos cortarlo qué
a cortarlo
y bueno vamos a rellenar verdad para que
no se vea sí ok y ahora vamos a pegarlo
aquí abajo muy bien aquí tenemos
justamente todo lo que hemos estado
haciendo ok y ahora vamos a ver si
podemos dibujar la imagen espejo o la
imagen reflejada en el espejo muy bien
entonces si digamos si éste es nuestro
espejo entonces nosotros podríamos poner
esto más o menos así
cada verdad aquí algo así y bueno si
empezamos a dibujar la imagen reflejada
tendríamos aquí nuestro anillo
aquí tendríamos un anillo
este enlace doble correspondería a este
de aquí muy bien aquí arriba aún
tendríamos nuestro oxígeno que íbamos a
poner el enlace doble con el oxígeno y
finalmente esta cuña quedaría de este
otro lado a la derecha
ahí estaría nuestra cuña y finalmente
aquí está el enlace doble y el enlace
sencillo verdad entonces ahí tenemos
nuestra imagen reflejada o también como
más propiamente si lo decimos de forma
más propia es nuestra imagen especular y
si nos fijamos bueno claramente este
sigue siendo el centro de quiralidad y
ahora las prioridades siguen siendo este
sería el primero entonces el segundo
sería este de aquí verdad y el tercero
sería este de acá abajo entonces si le
asignamos la orientación ahora podemos
ver que va en este sentido que va en
contra de las manecillas del reloj
entonces por eso es que podemos decir
que esta es la s carbono verdad a este
le asignamos la letra s y esta es la s
carbono verdad otra forma de poder
pintar esta misma molécula sería por
ejemplo calcar digamos la que teníamos a
la izquierda aquí tendríamos el enlace
doble aquí tendríamos nuestro anillo
aunque y voy a tratar de hacerlo más o
menos rápido simplemente la copiamos
igual verdad pero en vez de poner una
cuña ponemos la línea punteada ok
entonces aquí tendríamos esto así este
enlace doble y por supuesto en la cuña
aquí tendríamos nuestro hidrógeno verdad
pero no lo voy a poner déjenme omitirlo
si no es realmente no es difícil
convencerse de que esta es la misma
molécula que la que tenemos arriba
verdad simplemente digamos que le
estamos viendo por atrás y de todos
modos tenemos la misma orientación y
sigue siendo la ese carbono ahora bien
lo realmente interesante de la r carbono
y la s carbono es que son en anti o
menos el uno del otro pero de hecho
tienen colores distintos la r carbon a
de hecho huele como a la hierbabuena
vamos vamos deberíamos anotar eso
esta molécula ayer perdón huele como al
ayer hierbabuena ok
mientras que la s carbona tiene un un
olor más bien como el comino de prado
de prado qué
que en algunos lados también se le
conocen como semillas de
semillas de alcaravea ok pero eso estos
dos tienen distintos olores verdad
de hecho lo que podríamos concluir es
que la naturaleza en sí misma espiral y
nuestros receptores en la nariz también
son quirales de hecho estas dos
moléculas dado que te dan distintos
olores nos dice que son en anti o meros
que se atan a distintos receptores en la
nariz y que tienen distintos olores así
que la naturaleza realmente es
tridimensional y esa es una razón por la
cual estudiar la estéreo química es muy
importante